[Music]
today we're talking about imposter
syndrome and what to do when you never
feel like you're enough
we're going to be talking to a young
woman whose father-in-law is struggling
with mental illness
who's giving away his things and what
her and her husband can do
next and finally we're going to be
talking to a small town girl
who's living with their husband in a
lonely world and they're both wondering
can they get on that train to anywhere
should they move from that small town to
the next big thing
stay tuned
hey good folks i'm john and this is the
dr john dolone show
a live show where we show up we walk
alongside hurting folks
confused and troubled people and
neighbors just trying to figure out what
to do next
we talk about it all on this show
anything and everything no matter what's
going on in your heart
in your mind and your family there are
millions of other people across the
country
and across the world who are dealing
with what you're dealing with so give me
a call we're going to talk about love
loss family issues infidelity finding
love again
and we may talk about awesome husbands
like stephanie spino's husband stefan
stephanie wrote in about her husband
stephanie here's what she said
she says stefan spino is an amazing
husband
but he's really the best friend i could
ask for in my darkest time he has pushed
for me to get help
i only started going to therapy for him
because i didn't really even see a point
in investing in myself
he saw that in me he sees the good and
the value in me even when i don't
he's my biggest hype man he's so proud
of me and he makes me feel safe
but at the heart of it he just sees me
he makes me feel deeply known
stefan if you hear this i love you this
is her talking but i love you too
brother but this is her
seven years simply hasn't been enough
i'm glad we have a lifetime more
we're gonna talk about husbands like
stefan spino
good for you brother thanks for loving
your wife for seeing her for who she is
and for being with her that's awesome so
this show is about all of it we're gonna
put some positivity in the world
we may laugh with you and we may laugh
at you just give me a call whatever's
going on
i'm here to stand with you one eight
four four
six nine three thirty two ninety one
that's one eight four four six
nine three three two nine one or you can
email me at ask
john ramsey solutions dot com that's
j-o-h-n
ask john ramseysolutions.com all right
let's go straight
to the phones let's talk to mike in
green bay wisconsin mike good morning
brother how are we doing
good morning i'm doing well yourself i'm
doing very very good how can i help you
this morning man
well thanks for taking my call i uh i'm
a i'm a business professional
and i worked on the business development
side of things and
i've been listening to your show and you
talk about anxiety and add in which
i was diagnosed with add when i was 14
years old and hated the medication life
of it
but the thing i struggle with the most
now and it really pairs with my anxiety
is impostor syndrome um like i just feel
like i'm
two steps from being found as a fraud or
that i'm gonna be you know that i'm that
i'm not good enough and i hate that
feeling and i
i got this inner critic inside of me
that i just want to evict
and i'd like to know steps that i could
take to to to get that inner critic out
and get that stuff out of my head dude
that's awesome man well thank you so
much for your trust here
um yeah walk me back where do the
intercritics show up
first uh
you know probably in my early 20s okay
uh i'm i'm 40 now but in my early 20s
i i just i didn't choose the normal path
i didn't go to college
okay um and so and i come from where
like
my oldest brother is like this super
high achiever right
and looking at his his shoes and his
path and
then looking at my path as well and then
finally when i moved into business
and started being successful in that the
uh
the the struggle was it still shows up
like you're like no you're gonna be
found out no you're gonna be found out
you're gonna be found out
but somebody pointed out the difference
between who and your brother who was
that
him it was him okay i think with him
i've struggled with him for a long time
we're
close but there's there's things from my
youth that have been
that are that are tougher that's what i
was getting at so my guess
is that narrative that you're not
this you are not enough or hey check out
what he's doing or check out what she's
doing
or if you would just fix the lawn better
whatever the things are right
that that's been going on for a long
time yeah
yeah it um yeah i can think back to like
when i was
16 i got a birthday card for him and all
it said was study hard
and i was just i'm just not your average
i wasn't your average student like that
i didn't i barely graduated high school
and uh just because mainly other
i don't know for a litany of reasons but
so so
before we go we go into this and here's
the deal i wrestle with imposter
syndrome myself
and so i i can talk from first-hand
knowledge and i think we can
land on a pretty good place here but i
want to acknowledge your brother real
quick
is there a chance that he loves you he
just didn't know how to do it right
oh 100 huh like i said i have i have a
good
like we're close there's certain things
that will trigger me about him
um i just i agree
that he just doesn't know how he doesn't
he didn't understand me
okay very cool well hey it takes a big
40 year old man to be able to look at
somebody and say
that hurts when you do that but i know
you're loving me the best you can so
good for you man
that will give you a lot more peace you
have to carry that baggage around all
right so
you work in business now you're doing
well
yeah yeah when's the last time you
colossally failed
and when i say failure just disaster
just turd bombed it when's the last time
that happened
i don't see i i necessarily have full-on
done that i don't ever look at anything
it's just like a complete fail like
there's
there's lessons learned there's things
that i've done that have not been
successful and
so when you feel them behind when you
feel like
and when you feel like an imposter give
me a scenario when that plays out
like a live real-time scenario
um man i wrote down thoughts and i
wasn't expecting this question
i don't have like a
um when you know i'll tell you one like
when um
when the company that i work for like as
it's growing
if my name is not attached to a uh i
don't wanna say like
yeah when my name is not attached to
like a purchase order or
some kind of piece of the dollars that
comes in it maybe it's a competitive
side that comes out of me or something
else that comes out of me
but it makes me feel like like not good
enough not
like i didn't do my part or something
like that ah okay
okay so that's actually i wouldn't
consider that to be
imposter syndrome that's a whole other
conversation about worth and value
right but at the end of the day let's
talk through imposter syndrome and then
we can talk through your specific
situation
so broadly speaking i experience
imposter syndrome as this underlying
who do you think you are right like what
are you even doing at this table what
are you doing in this room
and for me it is like obviously i
haven't been able to overcome it through
education
i haven't been able to overcome it
through financial earnings
and the more i did the research and the
more i've sat with people who are
world class leaders people who have
quote unquote one life right
presidents and doctors and lawyers and
those the fancy pantses
they all feel it too and it's this
pervasive sense of
what are you doing in here you don't
deserve to be here and
my experience has been those scripts
start when you're a little kid
it's this chasing of perfection this
chasing of
whenever i get a thing it's gonna feel a
certain way and then my feelings are
gonna be good forever
right i'm gonna see that one purchase
order and it's gonna have my name on it
and i'm gonna go
ah there it is and then the rest of my
life's gonna be pretty much good after
that right
and the reality is that's not true
that's not how the world works right
right and so yeah i what i always want
folks to do when they feel
not enough or they feel um
left out is i want you to to literally
and this is gonna sound cheesy and you
can roll your eyes i want you to write
those feelings down and then i want you
to demand
evidence from them okay and so that gap
and this is
less about imposter syndrome this is
just dealing with those feelings that
are flying around your head it can
incorporate imposter syndrome but
when you see that purchase order coming
across and your name's not on it
somebody made a big sale without you
and you immediately get that drop right
you immediately get that birthday card
and you open it up and it just says be
better
study harder right same thing yeah
yeah i want you to then immediately grab
a piece of scratch paper and
write down what that thought means to
you what that feeling is telling you
and it's probably going to say something
along the lines of they don't need you
here
i told you you should have got a degree
they're going to make these sales
without you
fill in the blank and then i want you to
look at what you've written down and i
want you to demand evidence of it
is there anything about that that's true
and usually the answer is no and when
you can demand
evidence of those feelings you can begin
over time to
really quickly move through them right
because that script of
that's going to run in your heart and
head that's been there since you were a
little kid
is going to be there my guess is um we
could go back to the add when were you
diagnosed i was 14 okay i was 14
and um they put me on medication and i
hated every minute of it i took myself
off like three months later
so before 80 before a 14 year old was
was
put on add medication you and i are
about the same age so that means you're
back in the
in the 90s yeah that was a big deal that
means you probably had several years of
hard hard to focus in class
some behavior issues not getting your
homework turned in and things like that
is that fair
yeah yeah 100 okay so there's a
lifetime of up to that point of you
getting a clear message from the adults
in your life
that you are not measuring up totally
that you are not just nailed it
your brain is busted and then they said
hey we got a pill for you
you're broken here's a pill and that
didn't work either right
and from those moments is when you begin
to
develop a counter cultural a counter
solution to the world some people in
this situation
myself being one of them doubles down i
end up with two phds and i'm always
chasing the next
thing that's going to supposedly fix me
and make me feel better about myself
other people walk away from education
completely
and they double down on themselves and
they go try to win at business
and you and me dude were chasing the
same they were chasing the same dragon
other people go to relationships and any
number of other addictions etc to try to
fill that hole that i'm busted
the adults in my life have told me that
clearly and i need to try to fix that
through
fill in the blank does that make sense
and so you are
never going to be able to find an
external solution
an external plug to an internal hole it
doesn't exist
and what you have to do is begin to heal
your feelings and your heart from the
inside out and what i
if the 19 year old me heard the
you know the dude in his 40s say you're
gonna have to heal your heart from the
inside out
i would have punched my own self in the
face okay i get how cheesy and lame that
sounds
but the reality is it's true you're
living a script that you've been
living for years and years and years and
so
you've got to demand evidence from those
feelings and then here's the other big
thing you've got to have
other people probably other men in your
life that will be honest with you
that you can trust and that will give
you
legitimate feedback up up down
right left and right do you have mentors
in your life and not mentors like i
go to coffee with a guy and pick his
brain but true
true mentors that you are accountable to
that you lean on that you can ask hard
questions and give you tasks and wisdom
and hold you accountable
yeah yeah i do yeah i've got i've got i
bought a group of five oh that's
incredible man you were way ahead of the
game brother that's awesome
you know the the book you recommended
once was uh scattered minds
and i started reading that and i'm not
all the way through it uh scattered not
scattered minds there's two different
books scattered minds is
written by one dude i forgot but
scattered is written by gabor mate
that's the masterpiece
oh i think that's the one okay either
one i'm reading the one by gamora mate
okay excellent perfect yeah
yeah and like the first two chapters
just about draw me to tears there you go
oh my gosh this is like the first time
i've ever felt you know
x like during like walking through that
process
there you go um and here's here's one
other ugly truth about imposter syndrome
if you will
um and this is just me being real and
just
two guys having a conversation in front
of a couple million people
it's this um there have been moments
when
the imposter part is a hundred percent
right
i have found myself at tables that i
should not have been at
i have agreed to speaking engagements on
topics that i didn't fully have fleshed
out and
i probably should not have been the
expert in the room on that deal
and there's some times that i sit down
and demand evidence from my feelings and
they're right
and it may be that there are better
salesmen at your office
it may be that you have been living out
of a deficiency mindset a not good
enough a chasing dragon's
mindset instead of understanding i bring
value to this company and i'm going to
work to be a better and better
business developer a better salesman a
better whatever it is you do
and those feelings of inadequacy are
right
and so there's something about looking
at those feelings and being honest if
they're wrong they're wrong and they
usually are
but there is times when they are dead on
and then i need to go back to school
i need to shut my mouth i need to um
start living and practicing what i
preach on the radio every day i need to
fill in the blank
and it goes back to um
demanding evidence from your feelings
and then having somebody a group of five
you guys can go and you can be like hey
i keep having this recurring thought
that
um i'm not like i'm i've
i've topped out in my business and i
keep feeling like
this is it for me and they might say you
know we've we've noticed that for you
man
and you're gonna have to work hard and
do something else or they may say you're
an idiot you're doing great keep going
right yeah
but at the end of the day if you don't
have a track record of failure you're
doing well
at the end of the day if you have
managed to figure out how mike's heart
and head works and you are continuing to
read you're continuing to grow you've
got a group of people around you that
are holding you accountable
then it's going to come down to the
lifetime task
of growing and learning to manage
demand evidence from those feelings and
and make them tell you the truth
make them tell you the truth and um
don't be afraid to share them with other
people
and i i promise you that impostor
syndrome will begin to just dissolve
underneath you
um while we're here uh kelly let me know
that we were gonna have a discussion
about imposter syndrome so we did a
little digging into it
um
we'll do a little nerd segment here but
the imposter syndrome it's a
psychological state
of doubting your own abilities and
achievements right it is
not a diagnosis you don't go to a doctor
and get diagnosed with imposter syndrome
it's just this fear of being found out
and
it i've done probably 5 000 public
speaking engagements in my lifetime
almost every one of them before i go out
i think who are you
who are you to be out on this stage i've
i can't tell you how many classes i've
taught
and i can't tell you how many times i
get in front of a group to teach a class
and i think
are you serious you're the best guy they
got that's impostor syndrome right it's
not a default your brain's not broken
your heart's not broken
it's this this looking for success
there's
the the bar of success moves on you in
in my life it's because i
i have not gotten good control of my
feelings and it's because i haven't
clearly defined where it is i want to be
i continue to say i want to be on a
stage great i want to be successful
great
what does that look like because man you
can make 10 million dollars then the
next goal is 100 million and you make
100 million bucks
and the next goal is a billion right um
the finish line keeps moving on you and
that's the great that's the great trick
of life right
um most people believe most
psychologists believe that
imposter syndrome comes from growing up
in high achieving families
and where you are told either explicitly
or implicitly
you're probably you're not really
cutting it same as mike was just saying
telling us here right
he's got folks in his in his home that
are killing it doing great and there's
just implicit
like you could probably be doing better
right um women
and underrepresented groups they feel it
more it is more prevalent in those
communities
often because they have the reality and
the narrative that they've got to work
harder to get the same things
and so they when they get them they
expect there to be a
like a trumpet sound and it's not right
you get that phd you walk across the
stage and then the real work comes
because now you got to go get that
10-year track job and now you got to go
now you got to go now you got to go
the machine just keeps running and so
there's this idea that oh i thought i
was going to get here and when i got
here
this was the ticket and it's like nope
that's just getting you in the front
door now the real work begins
it's especially prevalent in the
academic communities but it also is i
finally became a leader i thought when i
got this job where i made this money
everything would go
just fall into place nope those folks
marriages are struggling too and those
folks
don't like what they see in the mirror
either and it's this perception that
once i get to a place i'm going to be
good and it's just not so it's just
pervasive feeling like you don't belong
here right
and the last thing is man there have
been seasons in my life where the
imposter
syndrome is right where i feel like man
i should not be in here and i should not
and so some of that comes back to me
being honest with myself
me being honest when somebody asks me
hey we do the speaking gig on this
particular topic that i don't have a lot
of expertise on
that i have the courage to say there's
probably somebody better
for this topic than me right um so
anyway that's my thoughts on imposter
syndrome
i really appreciate the call mike um man
get control of those thoughts get some
people around you like you like you do
trust those folks
and um you're gonna be golden and here's
the thing let your uh little boy off the
hook
that kid that was told you're not good
enough that kid that was told you're
broke and that kid that was told
other good boys sit in class all day
other good kids do all their homework
and they never miss one
man hug that little kid that's still
fighting for you inside
let them off the hook tell them hey
brother we made it
we're good i'm kicking butt in business
i'm doing good my brother doesn't know
how but he loves me mom and dad love me
let that little boy off the hook all
right thanks for the call mike let's go
to uh heather
in my hometown of houston heather how
are we doing
i'm doing good how about you i'm doing
so good
everything good in old age town
ah i mean as far as you know as
good as we can be i guess i love it i
love it well how can i help this morning
um so my husband's father
is fixing to run out of money next month
um
we believe he is mentally ill
just undiagnosed okay and we're just
trying to figure out what to do because
he's
planning to be homeless
why
we're we're all unsure like
he called my husband uh father's day
weekend
and said hey i only have six months of
money
you and your brother come get what you
want from the house the rest is going to
the curb
and basically that's it like he's only
giving them
his junk with strings like they're not
allowed to give away
the junk he's giving them like it's
literally stuff that doesn't work and
everything has a price tag
but he's giving his house back to the
bank which doesn't make sense i mean
is he is he man that
that that sets off a lot of alarms for
me
that you're dealing with somebody that's
about to take their own life
and that's what everyone's asked and i'm
like i don't
see him doing that yeah but most
i don't say most folks often don't see
it coming because they think
that guy or would never do that or that
that that came out of nowhere
and then when they look back one of the
cornerstone moments is
calling people and saying come take what
you want and they start giving their
stuff away
i've never in fact i've never heard of a
planned homelessness
i've heard of people who sell all their
things to take an rv out to the woods
and they're going to live that way but
they've got a plan and adventure they
start selling everything so they can
have cash
i even read a book about a guy who just
chose to live cashless
and he volunteered and ate off the land
et cetera
but outside of some some significant
mental illness
um this sounds like somebody who's
on a dangerous trajectory there it needs
a a
a pretty immediate intervention what
does intervention look like has your
husband gone to visit with him and speak
with him in person
has his your brother's you know your
brother-in-law have they gone
really direct with him no
so it's a very complicated situation
with them
my husband is the main one that's close
to my father-in-law like my
father-in-law
never even actually told his other son
what was going on my husband told his
brother
um his dad actually told his brother
that um he's like oh i'm just getting
i'm just cleaning out the house
and so he is not close with them
and then my father-in-law told my
husband that
when i can't afford gas in my car i'll
just come and park it in front of your
house
and then i i've been staying out of it
my my father-in-law
doesn't necessarily respect either of
his son's spouses or
his sons for the matter and
so i asked my husband i said so what is
he gonna put on a backpack and walk away
like what are his plans but i feel like
every time my husband or even my
brother-in-law get around him
it's like they become this little boy
yeah
so here's what has to happen is
your husband has to go to wherever he is
and even if he's in california or in
oregon
oh he's a mile down the road okay even
better
um i would put this at a code red
intervention level watching somebody
cognitively dis like disintegrate
in front of you and either they have a
really
well thought out plan to take their own
life
a really well thought out plan to just
stop
with the pain that is life
and they're going to do it by just
walking down the street at which you're
going to get a call from the authorities
four days later or eight days later um
to come get him right and he will have
not eaten and not slept and if
god knows whatever traumas he's
accumulated in those few days
um but your husband's got to step
up and he's got to take his brothers
with him
and you're going to have to directly sit
in the home of your father-in-law
not you them and they're going to have
to have the conversation of what is the
plan you cannot do what you're doing
this is either a an extraordinary cry
for help
that your husband is just not responding
to
this is probably um your dad your
father-in-law
has history of erratic behavior and this
just feels like erratic
plus one and so unless i'm so glad
you're calling because unless
you're you know ten thousand feet away
from it it doesn't look as nutty it just
looks like
nutty plus one right just a little bit
more than dad's normal
chaos and there's some real red flags
here
so he he's been known up and down his
his mom had um i think my mother-in-law
said she
like my father-in-law's mom was
schizophrenic
and um bipolar and when she would get
off her meds she would try to commit
suicide
and so we've all we're all like okay we
see this in him but i feel like
my husband has given up on him like i
feel
and he just he's like i don't know what
else to do
he's a grown man he he is and you know
what he's done
he's setting down your husband's right
your husband's right
your your his dad is a grown man and at
the end of the day
if he wants to do something drastic he
can
and that's the heartbreaking thing about
loving people your husband probably has
a lifetime of exhaustion of dealing with
this too
and i get that as well um
there is a in in a safety situation
so your husband does not have a lifetime
of abuse your husband doesn't have a
lifetime
of having to
ward off his old man from from
trauma from painful things
then there comes a moment when you got
to step in and save your dad from
himself
or and or
he's got to have a safety plan at his
home too which means he needs to
look his father in the eye and say if
you park your car at my house i will
have it towed
you will not be welcome in my home
and i would tell you and i don't want to
talk bad about your husband
but if he's through with his dad
he has a moral and ethical obligation to
tell his dad
i'm through with you because it's not
fair to your to a old guy to a
to his dad who is slowly losing it not
doing well
on a significant cognitive decline to
have a plan
that is not going to be it's not going
to be lived out in reality
and his own son won't be honest with him
and so for your husband's sake for and
here's the deal
it is for your husband's sake if you're
if your father-in-law hauls off and does
take his own life
that will weigh on your husband's heart
for the rest of his life
if yeah he shows up at the front door
and it turns into a whole
melee in a situation and then after a
mess and then you and him have to fight
and
y'all got kids and and and anne and then
that car gets towed eventually anyway
you're gonna have created a whole bunch
of unnecessary chaos because you didn't
plan ahead
and so if i'm if i'm you the
conversation to be had
is number one you and your husband have
to sit down and co-create a plan for the
moment
his father pulls up in front of your
house and says i'm moving in the
backyard
are you going to call the police are you
going to call social services
um i know there are several um elder
mental health associations there in
houston
are you gonna call one of them to come
get him
because it's not a character issue if if
he has schizophrenia it is not a
moral issue he's sick he's he's hurting
right um
and you need to sit down with your
husband and tell him you talked to
deloney on the radio he can call me
tomorrow
um but he has a moral and ethical
obligation
as far as i'm concerned he must go sit
down with his father and say what you're
doing
isn't um isn't a good idea you don't
appear to be well
you can't just give your house back to
the bank you cannot just
give all your stuff away and wander off
into the night we're worried about you
and we love you and we care about you
let's get you the help you need and then
he's right he's got to be vulnerable
and then his dad's going to be able to
do whatever his dad wants to do
but your son and his brothers need to go
sit down and have that conversation
and here's the deal that sucks i hate
that for you i hate that for him
i hate that for everybody in that family
dealing with
advanced mental illness and um a parent
is devastating so hard um
but that's what we got to do so call me
back after those conversations i'd love
to hear how it plays out i want to hear
how
your husband i have confidence in him
he's going to step up and do the right
thing
and go sit down and have some hard hard
conversations i know that little boy
pops out every time dad shows up and
that little boy's got to be let go your
husband's got to step up and do the
right thing
and his brothers need to step up there
and be there with him too
so thank you so much for the call um
let's go to one more let's go to bailey
in des moines iowa bailey how are you
this morning
i am good john how are you so good so
good
so how can i help this morning yeah
thank you for taking my call
so me and my husband move back to our
hometown
after an unplanned pregnancy in 2017 to
look closer to family for help
okay but my question is deciding whether
we should live in our hometown for the
rest of our life and raise our family
or maybe actually move again to get a
little space from family
so my guess is you're asking that
because you want to get a little space
from family
yeah i mean i love them and appreciate
them
but uh both of our parents are divorced
so we have four sets of grandparents
and now we're in very close proximity to
three of them and it just gets to be
overwhelming
and i love them so when i say this i
don't want to sound negative but
we don't want the life our parents had i
don't know how to say that without
they're not bad people i just we want to
we have different values for our
marriage and
sometimes i don't know if it's the
healthiest to live around them hey
hey bailey can i stop you there for a
second yes go ahead
don't apologize for that you know what
that makes you that makes you an
absolute gangster one of
um the the therapy researchers who i
love terrence real
says that family trauma burns through a
family tree
like a forest fire until somebody has
the courage to turn
and face it and that's what you and your
husband are doing
and so what you are doing is
generational work it is legacy work
you are literally making your family
tree different
because of the hard hard choices you're
making so never
um don't beat yourself up for wanting a
different life than what your parents
had
yeah cool thank you yeah it's just you
know we do
stuff differently we're the weird ones
yup we do dave ramsey we stop
drinking our hometown is a very
blue-collar town it's a lot of drinking
everyone knows everyone but there's a
lot of great things that have come from
it like
me and my dad have got better in our
relationship we've got
i mean it's cheaper living so it's just
we pro and con this decision back and
forth back and forth and
until we're blue in the face and we just
can't decide if we're holding our family
back and our marriage back
or are we over dramatizing living in our
hometown
it's not like the worst place in the
world but
i don't know it's just a constant
conversation in our marriage
you are living on the polls
right and so i want to give you some
peace about the middle
you could move for a couple years and
try it out
and it's going to be no worse for wear
you've made your
decision in either or and life is just
too twisty and
wacky and weird for anything to really
ever be either or
and so um a couple of things to think
through
wherever you all move you two will go
with you
and so if your marriage has wonky things
that y'all need to work through if
you've got relational conflicts if your
sex life isn't what you thought it was
going to be
if you don't like how he
deals with kids homework or whatever
those same things are going to travel
with you
right so will all the free babysitting
that will go away
right um the other side of it is
if you have a very clear path of where
you want to go you say that you want
different
lives you want to have a different
family tree you love your family
you love them deeply i can hear it and
yet you want something more you want
something different
both of those things can be true at the
same time and both of those things can
be
just and right at the same time that's
all good
what i want you to do is be really
explicit about what you want to be
different
because you're going to chase a feeling
and that feeling will never show up for
you
you're going to assume after we've been
married for 15 years
and we're not drinking anymore and we're
out of debt that suddenly everything's
going to materialize and it doesn't work
like that
you have to be able to know i want both
a beach vacation
and i need to understand that when i get
to the beach i'm still going to get
sunburned and i'm still gonna get itchy
from dirt right those two things are
both true
and most people have destinations and
dreams but they end up being just
feelings of what's gonna be like when i
get on top
of the pyramids in egypt it's gonna be
hot
right it's going to be hot and you're
going to be tired
it's going to be when you get down and
reflect on the journey and what we did
right so
you got to know why you're moving what
what ex
specifically what's that picture of our
life we're going to look like and then
live into that
and then if you got to move move you got
to move move
i i left a few years ago left texas left
everything i know every friend i had
um every family member of mine lives in
texas
we're all everybody's there and yeah we
left
and my relationship with my family is
still super close i don't see them as
much anymore
we talk probably more often now and
i've made new great community here and
my family visits me and it's
wonderful and good um right do i miss
stuff
yeah of course i do and i've also found
parts of me that i
never knew existed which have been great
so sometimes i just feel guilty too like
our kids getting to experience our
grandparents
but then i i mean i i think i have a
good idea of why we want to be different
and what that means it's just a constant
and we had both had traumatic
childhoods and now we're living in the
hometown where all that trauma happened
and
i had a tragic incident happen in high
school and i don't know sometimes i feel
like i'm
swimming re-swimming in all of the
motions all the time
so let me uh let me help
you one hundred percent are
100 are and there's a good and a bad to
that
the bad is moving you're still going to
have those experiences unless you go
deal directly head-on with that trauma
unless you get a good trauma counselor
and you work through that
the the good part is yeah some of that
trauma is geographically located
when you drive down that same street and
you go past that same house and you run
into that same dude
or that same woman in the grocery store
you're just not going to do that right
if you live in arkansas right it's not
going to be there
but that clock that scanner that's still
trying to keep you safe
in the back of your heart and mind it's
still going to be running full blast
until you do the hard work of dealing
with those childhood traumas
so running running from it moving out
away isn't going to solve that
but it can definitely let the alarms
down a little bit so you can do that
healing work
i think the main thing i want you to do
bailey is to not live in either ores
live in next two to three years
okay and if you move away and you're you
want your kids to be
involved in your grandparents life keep
them involved in your grandparents life
instead of seeing them every single week
you're gonna see
once every three months for a week at a
time right the time will be batched and
it will be grouped together and about
day four you'll realize
this is why we moved and then you'll
leave and everybody will be good right
yeah and then if you move away and it
just sucks
move back right right i just
i didn't know if there's i was always
hoping like to
i don't i just don't want to move my
kids once they were established when
they're a little older we have a
three-year-old and a one-year-old
uh hey they're not established at all
they're three and one
they don't even know what day it is they
don't even know i think i think i've
told this
this story on the podcast but my wife
um she's a was a you know she still is
she's a brilliant scholar she was
um hired to come work at a school just
outside of sao paulo brazil
i took my son with me um we were i was
just a trailer right i went
and my son and i had two weeks of just
glorious time together i mean picking
fruit off of a tree avocados off trees
like on the street
right two cans landing it was it was
unbelievable
it was like fantasy and
he literally has absolutely no memory of
that whatsoever it doesn't even exist
and i thought we were doing all these
great bonding moments and
when we're old dude he doesn't remember
any of that and he was two
three four somewhere around there so all
that to tell you is
they are going to be established when
you and your husband
love each other deeply y'all are
anchored in together kids are resilient
they will be good to go with you okay
and so it's you guys
being together relationally making a a
concrete decision let's go do this let's
just go move here's the deal i can hear
your voice you've already moved in your
heart
you just need permission to go so here's
your permission go right
um and be prepared one of those
grandparents may pass away as soon as
you move
that happened to us one of those
grandparents may get
really angry with you one of those
grandparents may get super super jealous
and wish they had gone to any number of
things can happen
and any number of those things that
happen doesn't make your move wrong
doesn't make your fresh start wrong i
just want you and your husband to be
really clear super crystal clear as to
why you're going and where you're headed
what's your relationship going to look
like what are your values going to look
like
what are you going to do whether that's
going to a marriage therapist
a getting a community together a good
group of friends
what's that going to look like that's
going to get you to those values it's
going to get you to that new family tree
that y'all are planting
and you're nourishing and good for you
guys good for you that's so cool
all right um bailey you just made my
whole day um i'm gonna
uh do a curveball here i had some other
lyrics planned and then
we're gonna change them on the way to
work this morning
i found an old cd in my garage and i put
it in
and man this brought back some memories
um
for me in college when this record came
out and it was transformative for me
it's a hard record from one of the
greatest songwriters of all time ever
and she wrote hard challenging things
to me as a young guy that were pretty
insightful and transformative so
the the record is from the greatest
songwriter ever
um and this is what i think is her
greatest song
and it's a gentle it's a quiet song and
it's by any defranco
from her up up up up up release
in 1999 that's the name of the record
five ups
and the name of the song is angry
anymore and she writes
growing up it was just me and my mom
against the world and all my sympathies
were with her when i was a little girl
and i've seen both my parents play out
the hands that they were dealt and as
each year goes by
i know more about how my father must
have felt
my mom taught me how to wage cold world
war with quiet charm
but i just want to walk through my life
unarmed to accept and just get by like
my father learned to do
but without all the acceptance and
getting by that got my father
through i just want you to understand
that i know what all the fighting was
for and i just want you to understand
that
i'm not angry anymore i think i
understand what all this fighting is for
and i just want you to understand i'm
not angry anymore
if i could say those words i'm not angry
anymore
this is a dr john dolone's show